hi my name is Sonny I work for a
management consulting firm painting
company I'm a member of a career council
today we discussed about geopolitical
risk of a Korea Peninsula particularly
North Korea and some of the models that
we've been working towards the
unification in a peaceful coexistence of
two Koreas are largely did not work and
we spent the deception talking about
what are the new ways to improve our
relationship and the relationship with
the air with the others they're one of
the ideas we did talk about was
basically invest into North Korea
leveraging in third world countries in
the country's this in a in a
confrontation with North Korea and
turning away from a subsidy model to our
investment model where natural resources
in both Korea is highly sought after by
many countries and this is one way we
can help them out the other way we
talked about is some of the religious
channels that we could use to help North
Korean orphans bilateral help of China
there's something we're pushing through
is a Korea Council is something we're
trying to help also we're trying to
invite the North Korea councils to a
world economic forum held in Asia next
year that's something that's
revolutionary and it's something that's
maker working newsworthy incoming email
can be lazy boy